yennefer of vengeberg comes from nothing  but her determination and strength make  her one of the most powerful and  dangerous Mages in The Witcher on the  Netflix series Jennifer is played by  Anya chalotra and like Jennifer in the  books talotra has long black hair she  wears Violet contact lenses to show her  Elven Heritage the show's Yen also often  wears black and white clothing the  characters preferred color scheme in the  novels in The Witcher video games  Jennifer is voiced by Denise goth and is  introduced in The Witcher 3 the wild  Hunt the game version of yennefer is a  closer match to the character in the  books her hair is still black but it  falls over her shoulders in a mass of  dark curls she also has violet colored  eyes and wears her trademark black and  white attire the video game yennefer  appears to be some years older than  chalotra yet age doesn't mean much when  you are practically immortal